ce dimanche c'était la fête des mères
l'occasion de leur offrir de jolis
cadeaux comme les fameux collier de
nouilles sauf que la fête des mères
pourraient porter prochainement un
nouveau nom remplacé la fête des mères
par la fête des gens qu'on aime l'idée
fait polémique une proposition qui a
pour but d'alléger la peine des familles
monoparentales ou homosexuel et qui fait
aujourd'hui polémique sur les réseaux
sociaux ils veulent remplacer la fête
des mères par la fête des gens qu'on
aime quelle idiotie supplémentaires
alors êtes vous d'accord avec cette
proposition
une info quelle idée aussi
supplémentaires anormalement et je vois
gilles verdez dire oui déjà
benoît gilles verdez dit oui je sais que
je vais démarrer la semaine on met donc
je vais démarrer par quelqu'un voilà
raymond on fait quoi alors mais j'étais
pas très bon quand tu démarres
c'est pas ta force non mais toi tu es
bien tu manges tu dois être honnête cela
dessus j'étais bien faut laisser
chauffer tout le moins un tour mais deux
sujets séparés
si je trouve pas de place qu'on y avoir
entre être encore plus énervé non mais
je sais que ben oui on pourra dire c'est
absolument ridicule et grotesque et
juste à la mode on est dans un camp de
suning hystérique qui est ridicule les
yeux pour qu'on fait quand céline
culture le truc il faut tout est tourné
chez les wanna plus doit dire que c'est
les mamans dessus à toi que c'est laid
pas passer mes romans matin alors moi la
fête des gens qu'on aime mal et nous
répondons devait de fêter pour toi parce
que moi je t'aime n'était pas ma mère
mon nom mais qui vous a donné la parole
pardon mais pour l'instant reste à porto
pour l'instant je veux te dis oui oui
mais pour l'instant je veux que des noms
après vous ouvrirez la toile vous non
c'est sûr que non ah non vous voulez des
noms donc non je peux parler oui non
mais c'est sûr que nos gars c'est sûr
que non c'est très bien mais d'aller
mouiller va parler négative ou c'est sûr
que nos accords pas si sûr que d'accord
héros d'une dérogation au
canada du président du mal mais ce sera
dans l'équipe président de groupe non
mais je vous le dis c'est pas de votre
non pas vous
vraiment pas parler après gilles
boyer j allez vas-y à 8 ans non mais la
fête des mères c'est très bien contre
lui la fête des biens qu'ils te produire
sur un autre réservé fait capte pas tout
perdre
quand on a une âme et à ce qui nous aime
et qu'on aime mais malheureusement tout
les sites non c'est une idée dégueulasse
non bâti quand on admire qui nous aime
et qu'on aime c'est bien mais
malheureusement toutes les situations
familiales ne sont pas égales ya des
enfants et qui sont issus de familles
monoparentales homoparentales des
enfants battus maltraités et des enfants
qui n'ont pas de maman et à l'école
j'avais un camarade qui n'avaient pas de
maman sa maman était décédé c'était
terrible c'était à chaque fois il était
extrêmement mal à l'aise toujours été
mal à l'aise donc c'est une très bonne
idée pour les enfants fait alors ça aux
enfants alors supprimer quoi du temps ça
n'a rien à voir l'entraidé mais ça
travaille à sa maman directement à
pierre commence sa maman mais j'en sais
rien mais alors qu'elle s'appelait
catherine alors il fallait supprimer à
sainte-catherine
non mais non c'est moi mais maintenant
on a versé palmyre ti dans ce cas là
pour supprimer tous les fruits c'est le
primeur voilà 20 millions c'est pourquoi
il va très bien merci oui moi mon papa
s'appelle papaye faut bien
d'accord que c'est pas une directive de
l'éducation nationale c'est la
discrétion des maîtresses et donc les
maîtresses quand elle voit que dans la
classe il y à un élève deux élèves aux
élèves pour qui sa fausse aussi parce
que le cas particulier est le suivant il
a peut-être ou de papa ou la maman est
décédée ou tapas udc ge et c'est dans
ces cas là pour qu'il ait pas de
différence au sein de la classe c'est
valérie la maîtresse bat
des cas particuliers moi j'avais pas de
papa ça me dérangeait pas ça me
traumatiser pas qu'il a fait des
pêcheurs
à la raison sinon dans la salle et ça
lui aussi donc perdu son père s'appelle
gira état et on perd malheureusement une
partie battue va pas enlever la saint
gérard
je veux dire et puis après moi mon voilà
et dans ce cas là tu fais pas tu te fais
pas le jour de l'an parce qu'il ya des
gens qui voient l'année prochaine
mais dans ce cas là bah oui dont il met
la cedh escalade n'avait pas un jour qui
passe sans que je donne la parole
c'est maintenant que ça se joue pour
vous julian ce sont les trois prochaines
semaines donc je vous dis filer doux un
manitou toute l'année un âne ne compte
pour you contenant la balance on gagne
des points quoi si on bat lens qui a
parlé ont bien sûr bien sûr sur l'action
de libération est la bienvenue ici
la mesure où elle est bien fait d'accord
je le répète en voilà tout délation est
la bienvenue ici bien entendu si tu veux
dire quelque chose on pousse ballon sur
un truc sur tes petits camarades
n'hésite pas voilà c'est ouvert alors
récompense non moi j'ai dit valérie tu
dis l école mais vous inquiétez pas pour
les maîtresses les maîtresses elles
savent en septembre quand elles prennent
une classe fin septembre elles savent
déjà elles ont les profils de tous les
enfants elles savent déjà qui va être en
difficulté sur toute l'année elles
savent déjà qu'ils à papa qui a pas de
moment qui a qui a des difficultés chez
lui on enlève la fête des mères toutes
les mains des moments comme on a fêté la
science comme on a fêté on fait quoi en
fait plus il à dire on appelle plus nos
mères ont ce on envoie plus de bouquets
de fleurs à la moye la dernière fois je
dérange gaiement dans la voiture je jure
que c'est vrai j'ai écouté au soleil de
jenifer et j'ai un copain qui
vraiment king poupe ouais voilà qui me
pose problème mais jin et bin et ben
elle dans ce cas là je n'écoute pas
[Applaudissements]
lui mais coûte au soleil alors que moi
j'ai une peau à problèmes voilà non mais
voilà c'est ainsi seulement raymond va
dans mon sens tu vas dans mes sens que
les maîtresses ont ri courant donc cette
hausse est la maîtresse qui décide c'est
l'établissement scolaire et dont il a
maîtresse n'est pas l'éducation
nationale qui dit unis alors des
malheurs et finit là je suis d'accord
mais si tu as une classe de vente de 30
élèves sur trente élèves il ya eu des
cas dramatiques comme maladie il ya des
décès voilà c'est dramatique il ya deux
enfants mais il ya quand même 28 enfants
qu'on leur maman donc on s'aime pas seul
dans ce cas la droite avec capote
l'architecte enfin regarder
tranquillement la télé
c'est un mec heures on le chauffe
toujours livrer manta sont à aucune
initiative jamais d'idées tout ça sur
quoi on tombe gifi les idées de génie
[Applaudissements]
c'est ainsi une baisse est traumatisant
pour la fin segment matinée c'est
traumatisant c'est traumatisant ah oui
oui bah oui c'est comme vous quand on
passe devant kiabi ou à la mode à petit
prix c'est traumatisant
[Applaudissements]
magasins
[Rires]
tout est comme ça voudrait-il par le
traumatisme
mais c'est insupportable et on va pas
faire parler tout monde là dessus j'ai
pas faire deux ans mathieu
à dire oui à un mot la fête des gens
qu'on aime c'est une très belle idée
mais notre jour ou pas et la fête des
mères et on garde une autre très belle
conclusion à raison oui mais ces braves
gens et si je vous surprend parfois sur
tout le monde dit que t'es con comme une
[ __ ]
me c'est énorme et c'est non je vais
jamais der wiel en guise allez je me
laisserais pu dire mais georges habache
je me bats pour dire tu te trouves pour
garder voilà l'intelligence le bouillant
là lui aussi voilà non non non tu
soulignes agit non non je te le diras
valérie que la meilleure du monde tu vis
dans le monde des bisounours et rémois
n'ont désormais nuit des temps des mères
indignes en a dans la digne des temps
des divers bouvier bouchons depuis la
nuit des temps mais c'est maintenant
qu'on n'a plus le droit de parler des
maires je suis désolé il ya un guide de
recommandations peu de communication
incluses il a été distribué à la
commission européenne qui a été supprimé
après qu'on a on veut nous en arrivons
juste dire que les tests on va dire
j'aime alors venez fêter la noël avec ma
mère je vais dire je vais fêter la fête
de fin d'année parce qu'on a plus droit
de dire noël avec un gens que j'aime non
mais bon arrêt
gfr
tout le monde s'en foutait maintenant
c'est autre chose à l'autre on va pas
faire débat là dessus c'est bon